la presentación del nuevo presupuesto
que es la hoja de ruta de los impuestos
y de la política fiscal aquí en el Reino
Unido se da en medio de una nueva
jornada de huelga de más de 400.000
trabajadores de diferentes sectores
entre ellos los empleados del metro de
Londres creando un completo caos en el
transporte público de la capital
británica también están en huelga los
doctores Junior desde hace varios días y
algunos empleados de la bbc que exigen
mejores salarios para hacer frente a la
inflación que está disparada justamente
la crisis en el costo de vida y cómo el
gobierno puede ayudar para que todos los
hogares puedan salir adelante en medio
de esta coyuntura económica fue la gran
protagonista de la presentación del
presupuesto hoy en el parlamento el
ministro de finanzas Jeremy Hunt dijo
que el país evitaría la recesión técnica
Pese a que el fondo monetario
internacional proyecto que este país el
Reino Unido será la única potencia ya
que estará en recesión dentro de los
anuncios más importantes en ese
presupuesto está uno bien destacado Y es
que los niños a partir del primer año de
vida podrán tener 30 horas a la semana
de Cuidado gratuito para que sus madres
son más de un millón de madres de
mujeres puedan regresar a los trabajos a
reinsertarse en la economía además
también anunció un plan multimillonario
para incentivar inversiones En negocios
y también el gobierno extendió por tres
meses más las ayudas con las facturas de
la luz a los hogares que más lo
necesitan